that should be turned into a candle not
Gwyneth Paltrow's princess die clickers
you like burning hair smells like human
hair I like that she's trying to sell
these kind of candles to Millennials I'm
like they don't want vagina candles they
want us eating incense the Millennials
are way ahead are you going way ahead
you and Glenn ahthe Paltrow she came out
with a candle that is supposed to be
scented like her own vagina $75 a pop
but he's already sold out you can't
trust a person to create a candle that
smells like their that's right China
because they're going to portray their
vagina in the best possible way somebody
else would have to come in and produce
the candy Asiya tones
yeah I'm a Brad Pitt to create a candle
that smells like Gwyneth Paltrow's
vagina it's gonna smell like five
knuckles in a Super Bowl ring at first I
was angry like this woman is so out of
touch with the real world and then I've
realized no she's a marketing genius or
at least her marketing team doesn't want
to buy a candle just I mean do you know
that what a great gift it is to have a
box that says in the box is box the box
says this smells like my vagina and it
says Gwyneth Paltrow under it like you
know that's one of the great gifts of
those Miley's as well in the US is that
Lily or is that an old kid where it's
very vaginal flower looks like Aaron
teasing me floral whoa look at the
design it's literally got flowers on it
Georgia O'Keeffe painting what does that
image say about her labia Allah I feel
like ah yeah I think you're right big
chunky meaty my vagina yeah available
now $75 yeah good for her what a [ __ ]
legend day I wish I could say I want to
smell I want to sell like like a a body
spray that smells like my booze can the
whopper I don't know Paltrow in the
conversation about all these like genius
hard-working crazy mogul people who go
from being actors to creating these
other businesses is huge people make fun
of her but she's very successful with
this group yeah and every single thing
hits the headlines for some reason
everything
look I stupid Gwyneth Paltrow is and
she's like okay you're gonna just buy
all the products then she's I'm just
covered on a bed covered in money just
yeah never join it you know what my
vagina smells like cash I hope the
camera yes you know how in love with her
I'd be one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM f
[Music]